RESPONSIBILITY AND GETS THE
CREDIT FOR MAKING IT THAT WAY.
AMERICA.
LET'S BRING THE PANEL.
JONATHAN SWAN, AXIOS.
A.B. STODDARD.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY ARI FLEISCHER.
ARI, STATE OF THE UNIONS CAN BE
LAUNDRY LIST BUT SOMETIMES THEY
CAN HAVE AN OVERALL MESSAGE.
SEEMS LIKE THIS MESSAGE FROM THE
EXCERPTS AND WITH THE PRESIDENT
SAID TODAY IS ABOUT UNITY.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
DONALD TRUMP NEEDS TO PREACH
TONIGHT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE HIS BIGGEST
AUDIENCE OF HIS PRESIDENCY.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE SOMETIMES
50 MILLION PEOPLE WATCHING.
IT'S AN UNFILTERED CHANCE TO
SHOW PEOPLE WHO YOU ARE AND
WHAT'S IN YOUR HEART.
THE FORUM IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT
DELIVERS THAT SPEECH, IT IS MADE
FOR PRESIDENTS.
IT'S IN A SIGNAL TO PEOPLE AT
HOME WHEN THEY HEAR THE
REINFORCEMENT OF WHAT HE'S
SAYING THROUGH APPLAUSE.
EVERYTHING FAVORABLE FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
HIS WEAKNESS IS HIS UNFAVORABLE
RATINGS.
STILL UNDERWATER.
ESTATE OF THE UNION LIKE THIS,
ESPECIALLY IF IT'S UNIFYING, IS
DONALD TRUMP'S DIRECTION.
COMES TOGETHER.
WHETHER THEY ARE ON THE SAME
SHEET OF MUSIC ON THE AGENDA,
THEY ARE ALL IN THE SAME ROOM.
THE PRESIDENT MAKES HIS PITCH.
>> I THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT
A BUNCH OF DEMOCRATS, LAWMAKERS
ARE SAYING THEY WANT TO BOYCOTT
THE EVENT.
MEMBERS OF THE COEQUAL BRANCH OF
CONGRESS OR IN THE PRESIDENT'S
ADMINISTRATION.
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
DONALD TRUMP TO TELL A GREAT
STORY ON THE ECONOMY.
STOCK MARKET GAINS, THE BENEFITS
OF DEREGULATION, THE SUCCESS OF
PASSING TAX REFORM.
DIFFERENT THAN LAST YEAR'S JOINT
ADDRESS TO CONGRESS ON
LAP ON THOSE TOPICS.
WE ARE TOLD HE IS GOING TO
EXTEND AND ALL THOSE BRANCH TO
TOUGH ON BORDER SECURITY AND THE
THINGS HE CAMPAIGNED ON BUT I
THINK IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
HIM TO SAY WE HAVE DONE WHAT WE
CAN ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE AND
IT'S TIME TO REACH ACROSS THE
AISLE I WANT TO BE PRODUCTIVE.
IN LIGHT OF THOSE NUMBERS ARI
TALKED ABOUT IN THE HEADWINDS
REPUBLICANS FACE GOING INTO THE
MIDTERMS CREATES THE BEST
POSTURE FOR HIM.
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT'S JOB
PERFORMANCE.
HAVE YOU SPLIT DOWN THE GROUPS,
YOU HAVE REPUBLICANS, 86%.
TRUMP VOTERS 92%, DEMOCRATS 11%.
INDEPENDENCE HAD 38%.
PART OF THIS IS THE OVERALL
APPROVAL.
45%.
IT'S INTERESTING EVEN UNDER ALL
THE ATTACK HE'S TAKEN THAT HE IS
STILL MANAGING TO GET APPROVAL
IN MANY POLLS THAT'S IN THE MID
40s OR UPPER 40s.
THINK PEOPLE ARE STILL MISSING
IS YES, THE TAX BILL WAS DEEPLY
UNPOPULAR WHEN IT WAS RELEASED,
WHEN THEY PASSED IT, BUT THE
NUMBERS HAVE BEEN GOING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVING.
THEIR PAYCHECKS.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT
PRESIDENT WANTED TO KICK IN
BEFORE THE MIDTERM ELECTION.
I AM HEARING PEOPLE -- I HAD
LUNCH TODAY WITH A PROMINENT
DEMOCRAT WHO SUGGESTED THEY WERE
LESS THAN EASY ABOUT THE NOTION
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE THE
HOUSE.
I AM STARTING TO HEAR SOME DOUBT
ENTER PEOPLE'S VOICES ABOUT THIS
SUPPOSE IN FOREGONE CONCLUSION
THAT REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
LOSE THE HOUSE.
WHAT WE'VE HEARD, CONVENTIONAL
WISDOM OVER
ARI, YOU HAVE FIVE DIFFERENT
DEMOCRATIC RESPONSES TONIGHT.
FIVE DIFFERENT RESPONSES TO THE
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS.
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY IF YOU
HAD THIS, FIVE DIFFERENT
RESPONSES TO A DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT BY THE G.O.P. THAT
THERE WOULD BE A LOT OF STORIES
ABOUT CIVIL WAR, DIFFERENT
MESSAGES, NOT UNIFIED, NO
LEADERSHIP.
YOU DON'T SEE A LOT OF THOSE
STORIES.
>> OF COURSE YOU DON'T BECAUSE
IT'S NOT THE WAY MOST COVERAGE
WORKS.
IT'S A PRECURSOR TO THE 2019,
2020 PRIMARY WHERE YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE 15, 20, MAYBE 25
DEMOCRATS RUNNING.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM IS
GOING TO TRY TO GET TO THE LEFT
OF ONE ANOTHER UNTIL I FALL OFF
CANDIDATES TRY TO SLICE UP A
POLITICAL IDEOLOGY.
IT'S GOING TO BE A RACE TO THE
LEFT.
YOU WILL START TO SEE THAT
TONIGHT.
>> Bret: OBVIOUSLY UPHELD
CHALLENGES FOR THIS PRESIDENT
AND ONE IS THIS INVESTIGATION.
BUT REACHING ACROSS THE AISLE IS
PRETTY TOUGH IF DEMOCRATS ARE AT
11% AND LAWMAKERS DON'T SEEM
LIKE THEY ARE BUDGING TO WORK
WITH THIS PRESIDENT.
>> IT'S IN THE OUTREACH.
IF IT'S GENUINE AND HE'S NOT
TWEETING AND CALLING THEM LOSERS
TIMES, HAVING THEM AT THE TABLE
AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
IF HE ACTUALLY STAYS AT THE
TABLE WITH THEM AND SHAMES THEM
INTO THE PROCESS, EVEN THE ONES
WHO DON'T WANT TO BUDGE AND
STAYS IN NEGOTIATIONS WITH THEM
ABOUT HIS POSITION ON A FIX FOR
DACA AND THE DREAMERS, DOESN'T
CHANGE HIS MIND THE MINUTE THEY
LEAVE THE MEETING, HE WILL END
UP IN A RELATIONSHIP THAT CAN
BEAR FRUIT IN AN INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE.
I THINK THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS
WILL BE CONSEQUENTIAL.
HE CERTAINLY DOESN'T WANT A
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
A DEAL WITH CHUCK AND NANCY MUCH
THE CONSTERNATION OF HIS OWN
PARTY LEADERS.
EVEN THOUGH WASN'T REALLY A
SUBSTANTIVE DEAL.
IT WAS HIS FINEST MOMENT IF YOU
TONIGHT IS THE OPPORTUNITY AND
SO IS THIS MONTH.
ARE IN A PRETTY GOOD POSITION
NEGOTIATIONS, AFTER A WIN.
THE LAST SHOT DOWN SHOWDOWN.
>> I THINK THEY WERE SURPRISED.
THERE WAS SURPRISE THAT SCHUMER
PLAYED AT THE WAY HE DID AND
CAPITULATED AFTER THREE DAYS.
THE NEXT STEP AND ULTIMATELY I
THINK MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN
THERE WHO HAVE PAID ATTENTION TO
CONTROLS THE HOUSE, SENATE AND